wait a minute hold up
what every single shot in this movie is
when you can see the sky the entire sky
is sieging
action movies have to earn it right they
have to earn it you need to see the
actors doing this this is the most
artistic nuclear bomb CG rendering I've
ever seen as far as CG goes it's good CG
pretty
thanks to Betsy for sponsoring this
video stick around to the end so you can
find out more about Bessie's Black
Friday sale
what's up guys welcome back to visual
effects artist react today's a special
day because I just finished son of a
dungeon that means I have free time to
do other things dude the biggest
production corridors history has now
completed as of today the uploading of
the final episode yeah so obviously
we're watching this video you know
probably a week or two after that but go
check it out if you haven't seen it it's
on Corridor digital.com where we also
have extended react episodes which is
perfect because this episode is going to
be extended as
wait really don't you mean extended as
wow yeah no they'll add that in there
later what if we didn't we just dropped
a hard F-bomb Just Right on YouTube
[Music]
all right let's get into it
are we looking at the Grand Canyon
we're looking at a nuke oh actually this
is pretty sweet they even have all like
those little streamers up in the air for
the Shockwave testing yeah wait that's
what the streamers are for yeah
Shockwave testing oh look at the shock
wave going on I just realized this is
the most artistic nuclear bomb to CG
rendering I've ever seen the most
hipster nuke ever I love the lighting
yeah dude nailed it especially going for
that like crunchy black and white grade
on it too oh it's breaking down starting
to break down
[Music]
need
oh
I don't actually know where it goes from
here by the way this is probably I kind
of want to see what happens yeah where's
this going this is sweet like we're
still inside a nuclear mushroom cloud
right yeah so it's like it's one of
those things where I can't really
question the quality of the visual
effects when they seem so obviously
intentional when it comes to David Lynch
every single thing feels intentional
like every single Pixel feels
intentional like whether or not you feel
like there's any guidance to that
intention I don't know or if there's
coherence I think it's up to the viewer
a little bit I think this whole
interpretation has been that of a
nuclear blast you know particles and
energy and fire so I want to see that
nuke again let's go back to the game at
first I thought this was like an
infrared shot which is ironic because of
what we're gonna look at later it's
really powerful shot for a TV show
especially like in terms of nukes like
nukes are always kind of janky because
it's such a really hard flow physics
thing to like actually simulate without
having to just fake it and obviously
they're faking it here but like a lot of
great artistic decisions to make it like
really impactful the framing the
lighting the color it's all very heavily
art directed and guided but at the same
time it feels really realistic and
grounded the shock wave that expands and
like shock wave is perfect I don't think
I've ever seen a better nuclear shock
wave more Tastefully and accurately done
than this one this scene I'm fairly
certain is 100 CG and that includes the
entire environment if I was to do this
shot I would basically start by going to
like Google Earth do a 360 aerial of
this area and then run that through
polycam to get a 3D model
maybe even just taking like a topology
map and extruding the ground out of that
yeah I think people really underestimate
how easy it is to make 3D models of
things as long as you can go like
and look around it I happen to do a ton
of research on this uh this summer so
all those satellites flying around in
our skies what are they for lots of
things
[Music]
[Laughter]
high resolution lidars basically really
you can access the lidar data through
different like government websites so
it's becoming a lot easier to actually
create terrain like this because you can
get Point cloud data that's like one
meter resolution oh my God that's really
cool now something might be thinking
like why don't you just get an aerial
shot and compass in lighting I think
lighting lighting lighting lighting
lighting it's a nuke at night the nuke
needs to cast lighting and shadows in
the landscape and you're not going to
get that if you just use footage of it
well I mean you can it just wouldn't be
as detailed because now you're having to
like add in like lighting and stuff but
like if you look at the mountains up in
the top left they get reflected as if
you're shining a light up at the side of
the mountain you know it's like I mean a
big like a nuclear light but then from
there it's like all right you do some
Cloud Sims of like this little layer of
clouds you're getting like nice Parallax
as the camera's moving and then you just
do a Houdini Sim of a giant smoke cloud
and it's probably a few different
Houdini Sims Happening Here one for the
shock waves one for the actual smoke one
for the fire ball and all that stuff
what I know of the visual effects about
Twin Peaks is that they're usually kind
of janky and that's kind of the point
yeah we looked at the tiny head scene
right yes the ball head scene sorry he
turns into like a marble or whatever
yeah you know so we looked at another
David Lynch effect shot and we felt like
it was really janky but at the same time
it didn't feel like it was an accident
right yeah it's like the janky effects
they they're still evoking a very strong
emotional response and when that happens
it's no longer just a janky effect and
it's doing something there's art to the
jankiness and when it comes to David
Lynch I Can't Help but feel like that is
intentional because of how it makes
people react yeah you know in a way it's
like we've seen a lot of VFX explosions
but this one felt so different and it's
kind of exciting seeing somebody like
David Lynch use visual effects because
he uses them for such a different
purpose than everybody else it's such a
different style of Storytelling with
them and this shot is technically
probably easier to execute than like all
the stuff in Marvel I'm not oh yeah not
trying to downplay it obviously there's
amazing art Direction and simulations
happening it's not an easy shot but at
the same time like this hits me harder
Sam you think I'm going to show you a
nice new clip and not follow it up with
a janky nuke clip
oh The Walking Dead this probably has
the same budget as David Lynch's Twin
Peaks I don't know oh yeah dude The
Walking Dead but this is Fear The
Walking Dead is this a different show
yes this is like the spin-off of The
Walking Dead
so we're about to see nuke perfectly set
up right there and here comes
oh
cop out
all right they're showing us a bunch of
different perspectives so that their
perspective is a cop-out all right this
one I love this one
wait a minute
wait a minute hold up hold up hold up
what's up
dude this is like David Lynch
dude what she just transforms
not even any smoke it's like everything
in meal combusted and then no smoke but
that's not how that works
not only did it burn it's now burnt
it's done burning
they just had to fast forward through
that part really quick it's one of those
things where like they took the right
idea and only really used five percent
of it yeah which is like when a nuke
goes off it's like the most intense
sunburn it'll literally make paint to
just evaporate instantly add up to like
a couple miles away but it wouldn't Char
the back side of her body and also leave
no smoke everywhere or fire yeah it's
like now watch the size of the explosion
here just just look at it that doesn't
even look like a nuke it's not it's just
it's got to be stock footage honestly I
mean I doubt it's a custom Sim setup for
the shot I think this is well I mean all
of the smoke rolling over the hills is a
custom Sim so they at least have that
much I like but like that bomb is like
the size of like like it's like the size
of like what like a it's just a big bomb
it's not like a nuke it's just like a
big normal bomb it's like when they do
like the ammo dump detonations out in
like Iraq or Afghanistan the Shockwave
looks so good over the hills though like
seeing it roll over the hills and
there's no more trees it looks like a
miniature you know it looks like someone
shoots their Vape down at like uh I mean
I think it looks like a recreation of
the train like the scale's a little
wonky like it looks cool the actual
shock wave like it's not realistic but
it looks cool there's no atmosphere
compression happening there's you know
you're not actually getting any like
interaction in the sky which you would
get like where you'd have like the white
Vapors up here yeah I guess the reason
why this shot is just kind of bizarre to
me is because it seems very poorly
executed on top of some pretty Advanced
things happening and it's like they kind
of clash like the whole smoke Sim the
compositing of all that even like having
her as a crispy character and the ground
all be suddenly burnt all of those are
good ideas but just the marriage of
those ideas just doesn't
yeah it's like technically the shot's a
good shot but this is not what happens
when a nuke goes off everything doesn't
turn into Embers like it's been coated
in lava for two weeks well it's more
like it's like it's like order of
operations too that's the other thing
it's like pulling a guy in a wire and
then setting off the explosion you know
it's like that's the effect that I see
here
yeah
it's a great pyrotechnic explosion but
you pulled the guy too soon yeah yeah TV
shows it's always fun to look at TV
shows because they just don't have the
same budget as movies so it makes it
easy for us to look at things but
they're so innocent and pure yeah it's
like us so I have written a video about
the true scale of nuclear explosions
don't know when I'll start making it but
subscribe so that you don't miss out
when I eventually do but we do have a
video coming out tomorrow and it looks a
little bit like this do you remember
Frozen Crossing Alpha
everyone's Frozen in time and the
camera's moving through that when they
needed to speed up the shot they would
take the footage and fast forward it but
then you get the
but if they were able to just do a
Radiance field scan of the whole thing
they could pick and choose their camera
moves after the fact
[Music]
so I saw a movie this Summer that I
adored and that movie is called nope
Jordan Peel's third movie have you guys
seen it nope nope wait really I thought
you saw it I have not seen it
nope
this is a movie that seems to be a
certain way on the surface but is a
different movie underneath that so on
the surface of this movie it's like a
UFO film and so there's a UFO hiding up
in these clouds
we can't even really see anything yet
but it's working so well to create
tension you're just like we're pointing
the camera at something and I know
something's there I just can't see
I also moved and it's gone that's cool
that's a nice scene it's Moody first of
all every single shot in this movie in
this location at least when you can see
the sky the entire sky is CG because the
clouds are an actual character in this
movie and so they had to be able to have
full creative freedom on what those
clouds look like and what they do so
that's kind of like the reasoning behind
that but they still are shooting a lot
of this stuff at night but the problem
with shooting at night is that there's
no light and you know if you want to be
able to see the environment around you
you can't do that at night and so you do
this process called day for night
filming because what they were wanting
to go for is they wanted to kind of
emulate that sort of scary feeling of
being out in the wilderness in the
middle of the night when there's no
light anywhere and your eyes adjusts but
look at the quality of the light how
everything seems to be evenly lit yeah
so you can still see the mountains off
in the distance you can kind of see all
of your environment around you but it's
so dark you can barely make out anything
and there hasn't been a good way of
emulating that sort of look through day
for night and so the cinematographer and
the VFX team collaborated on this really
cool technique to basically combine
filming two different cameras at the
same time they filmed every shot on both
the IMAX camera and an infrared camera
through a crazy like stereoscopic rig so
they're using a mirror and one camera is
behind like the angled mirror and it's
getting the shot the other cameras on
the mirror and getting the lights
they're both getting the exact same shop
exact cameras but what the infrared
camera is doing is it's able to bring
out a lot of the detail in the mountains
and the landscape and you end up with
these different like luminance values
that a regular camera just can't get
yeah like with infrared plants reflect
into Reds they all appear white right
yeah this guy up here is black so you
end up with like a nighttime sky that's
really interesting but the problem is
that it's black and white footage and
there's still color in the night and so
that's why they had the IMAX camera to
kind of apply all the color onto the
luminance channel of the infrared
footage I wonder if the infrared helped
them out like the sand screens helped
out the Dune production I hope it saved
them time I hope it saved them time too
I know because I hear that I'm like
because I I don't know like I'm like
this is like a new idea of like oh wait
have we been just shooting day for night
all wrong having tried to film at night
trying to get it to match what you
actually see as a human being is very
very difficult like it's clear that a
lot of the foreground is lit normally
and then just rotoscoped and color
graded down but being able to just have
your landscape just something that you
can pluck from and you know I don't know
if they're taking the landscape from the
RGB footage or the infrared footage or a
combination of the two at the very least
you're going to get some nice crisp
shapes especially with the actor against
the background thanks to having like the
infrared versus the real camera they
haven't released any breakdowns on it
maybe it was something that looked great
on set and when it actually came time to
doing this stuff in post they're like we
didn't
there is a chance that that's the
situation I know I know but
a creative like filmmaking problem
solving that I love we need a good day
we're gonna involve infrared stuff it's
like yeah what we don't know behind the
scenes if it is the case is like yeah
it was good
all right real quick
since you guys haven't seen it there's a
really cool shot Christian go to the
Akira slide oh they're doing Akira slide
in this it's towards the end it's
towards the very end hold on so we since
we haven't seen it we're gonna go right
to the yeah I don't care wait didn't we
ruin Dune for you yes so far this is
Revenge this is Revenge all right
yeah
wow that's so funny really funny so like
so that's totally on a rig yeah that's
totally like on Rails basically yeah I
think what they did is probably did a
paint out where they had like some sort
of like steel like rail or guide that
yeah you can if you go into the top of
the shot you can totally see there's
like a paint out there because that's
that's a fully controlled action it's
like a like an amusement park ride see
right there yeah you see see that blurry
fuzziness of that line there yeah I can
actually see the track go off on the
ground briefly yeah it's like a solid
track that they have like an angled bike
and if they just go air you know yeah I
mean that's what you gotta do it's
because it's entirely unrealistic motion
it's impossible unless you're an anime
character you can't do it this is a
freaking Akira slide in the this movie
is pretty funny and Jordan peel was so
excited when someone asked me I was like
I gotta do it I gotta do the Akira slide
I was like hell yeah you did it was sick
it was also just so out of place that I
just couldn't help but cheer that did
not expect it yeah there's a bunch of
other really cool VFX in this movie
there's the whole chimpanzee there's the
design of the UFO itself and all of this
stuff at night you know nope great movie
I loved it would you recommend it yep
yeah the sequel's called yup
[Music]
the Samaritans is this one of those like
you know make a quick Buck International
Steven Seagal Market movies or is this
like a fiesta film uh like kind of like
a take at doing a superhero Thing a
little bit so this was recommended in
the comments they said take a look at
the de-aging of Sylvester Stallone
a lot of fire a lot of CG fire
CG Fire doesn't look very strong wait
that dude was just floating above his
hands of course
okay flashback wait who what the
wait
what uh he's like the handsome Chad meme
here's the thing if the whole movie was
CG and we cut to this shot I would be
like it's fine this would be fine but
the reason why that's not working in our
heads right now is that we know that
that's footage of him that's been
altered in a movie that's live action
and should look live-action yeah it's
weird to like go to love death and
robots for a minute
and then come back out of it yeah that's
like a full CG head yeah Straight Up
full CG head and you know what as far as
CG goes it's good CG pretty good
actually but like it's the wrong move
right now to be like full CG head it's
like whoa how's this kid totally fine
maybe there might be a super hot Powers
thing involved here somehow that we're
just unaware of it's impossible for me
to suspend my disbelief in in scenes
like this because I'm just like I know
how hot it's it's like water would
literally just boil this is a little bit
what happens when you don't have
practical stuff on set you don't quite
know where to gauge all your uh like
where what energy level should you be at
right now it's like I don't know how hot
is it the director said it was hot like
100 degrees Yeah Yeah I'm like 100
degrees that was the hottest day that
you can think of it's like wow that's
pretty 100 105.
dude that dummy oh my God wait a second
let's take a look at this dummy first
you're like can't turn into a dummy
quick
[Applause]
so mad about that animation that
rendered jump you got so much dude
Unreal Engine
Okay
superpowers okay he must we don't know
the context that's why he came back
that's why he came back to life dude
yeah he's got super powers and then this
shot this shot right here what the hell
you can only have blue color with the
blue wavelength in your life and there's
none of that fire is emitting blue
wavelength at the moment I mean he's got
blue jeans and a blue shirt on yeah it
would be gray in this situation yeah
they're just trying to make him stand
out a little bit more because in reality
he'd be like kind of like a faded
silhouette here but whatever in reality
you would not see anything because of
all the smoke yeah he's reality when you
can just make whatever you want right
just for reference right reference is
what you need to make a good shot just
Backdraft final fight this is the scene
that they're trying to do in VFX done
for real
foreign
yeah by the way how sick is that shot oh
wow oh my God that was a real Firestone
so those people were actually there dude
all the gas that gets thrown out and
then ignited and you're just hoping that
the barrel is not gonna land on you they
must be on wires I'm sure they're on
wires dude an ax fight in an exploding
Barrel Factory yeah like they've earned
everything to get here too so you're
just like yeah ax fighting exploding
Barrel Factory
foreign
that's a cool shot look at that dude a
fire stunt with the actual actor it's a
wire stunt and a fire stunt at the same
time without doubles man so cool you've
got the actors man for like doing this
too action movies have to earn it right
they have to earn it you need to see the
actors doing this you know and if it's
not gonna be an accurate it needs to be
a stun person doing an insane stunt and
they need to earn it like then you're
there like then you're in the show you
feel the tension so I guess now having
watched this my main note on this stuff
was Stallone I don't think the exposure
was correct yeah notice how this is more
yellow than orange and it's a little bit
more blown out but here what I'm mostly
seeing is just mostly a bunch of orange
and like red and red yeah it's like when
it starts getting too orange it looks
too CG to me you're right 100 and you
know part of the color grade but just
like fire when it's hot isn't orange the
actual color is putting off is like a
yellow white and then there's just like
a haze like a lenses and a smoke Haze
that lifts the black levels yeah
cause like here they've got a lot of
great fire elements they've got tons of
Ember little like heat ripples in the
air and they do have smoke in the
background but we're not getting that
sort of universal volumetric fog that a
freaking smokey room would have and it's
not lighting things up right it's like
all this smoke all this Haze in the room
should be bright and not only is the
fire bright but the Haze takes it light
and diffuses it so everything gets a
wash of brightness just like this room
is with daylight great fall lights well
it gets difficult because like if you
know you're going to be putting elements
behind someone or have to comp stuff you
don't want to fill your room with Haze
and fog because like okay now maybe it's
harder to track stuff or it's harder to
do that compositing so you know you film
the scene without the haze yeah and then
adding CG Haze back in it kind of sounds
easy but it's also kind of hard because
Hayes is very 3D yeah you basically
especially in the thick case you need
that z-depth that somebody's going like
this their hand is going to be more
clear than their face I feel like
they're like no I want to be able to see
the emotions of my actors and I don't
want to like obscure that but at the
same time it's like you can obscure it a
little bit if you're going to commit to
a burning room you got to take the pros
the cons the cons is it's gonna be hazy
you're not gonna see your actors very
well like this shot's great yeah uh this
isn't bad either that one's not bad at
all I would put a little bit more
foreground haze there but like yeah and
look how like they're not just covered
in sweat they're covered in soot and
dirt and grease they look like the place
was burning and of course like literally
neither of them have soot on them at all
I guess he did get hit with the hose but
that kid could use a little smudge you
know what it's funny coming back to this
now it really is not holding up as much
on our first viewing I was like yeah
this is cool you know it's like it's not
distracting like yeah the setting is
weird but visually it's working but then
if you see Backdraft and it's like oh
you know know so often people are like
the VFX brought me out of the shot and
it's like the VFX aren't bringing me out
of the shot here they're just they're
along for the ride yeah as I leave the
shot yeah this one's really hard to get
right and frankly I feel like if the
scene would have been just approached a
little bit differently and how it was
shot and directed you could have the
exact same visual effects and they'd
totally sell that being said elements
being used super cool like all those
Sparks in the air and like the burning
columns and stuff like that the tiny
like sprinkly twinkly ground fire and
stuff like little Groundlings the
Groundlings awesome like it's it's super
cool and vibrant frankly like if I was
shooting like a movie with a big room on
fire and this is like what the effects
house gave me I'd be amped I be like
this is good work it's just I would need
to make sure the scene I'm making meshes
yeah with what they're doing exactly
superhero movies are weird they're tough
man they're tough tone to get right at
the end
if you have any boom booms or fires that
we should take a look at let us know in
the comments below maybe we should do
another episode just about nukes I mean
we will let us know
oh Christmas has come early thanks to
our sponsor
I'm here to give the gift of best
of best mess Hey kid
come here have you heard about Bessie
shoes oh my God I got him I got him I
got him you think I don't know vessies
they have a patented Diamond text
material that keeps you cool in the
summer and all warm and snuggly in the
winter well of course I knew that boy
but uh did you know that they now make
gloves here
thank you what is going on with her well
here's another young lad have you been a
good boy I've been a wonderfully good
boy amazing well I brought you a pair of
vessels all right I actually I'm already
wearing my besties because my shoes are
100 waterproof meaning I can wear them
rain or shine it's pretty great keeps my
feet dry all the time oh well okay good
boy
um take a hat
it's waterproof as well oh
where's kid come from hello come here
boy yeah oh there we are yeah they're
lightweight and breathable it's like
just like wearing socks it's crazy no
well no you don't have to do that with
your hands you can wear these messy
gloves oh are you kidding me goodbye
good boy oh Merry Christmas
more good boys Matthew Jenkins Santa you
look a little thinner I thought Santa
would be all fat well I actually went
vegan this month but uh good to know
that bessies are actually also vegan oh
wow really what what do you got in the
sack there well I'm gonna give you a
pair of bessies young boy it's all right
I know you flew all the way down here
from the north of pole but I already
have vessies yeah I got like three pairs
what do you do in them I can wear these
vestes on a run I can stomp around in
puddles you know show off to my friends
let me talk to you boy come here let me
tell you something now now you may have
besties but what you don't have is Vesti
socks okay now the first hundred people
to use the code
amazing Revelations it looks like
everyone in the studio truly wears
Bessie sneakers click that link go to
bestie.com
for Amazing Black Friday sales remember
get your friends off the first 100
people
Good Times dude I mean that was cool I
didn't expect to have a bit of a theme
for this episode but I enjoyed it I just
I love looking at Backdraft I'm trying
to share with the world how cool
Backdraft is you ever slept on Backdraft
and of course as always you can watch
the extended version of this where we go
into even more rambling detail about all
of this stuff check it out on the
website quarterdigital.com yeah if you
missed one thing that we say you're
missing out well thank you for watching
and we'll see you next week or tomorrow
tomorrow we have videos on Sunday yeah
tomorrow we'll see you then but if
you're only coming back for this show
see you next week